(ethereal techno music)
(upbeat drum music)
- Hey, come on in.
(upbeat synth music)
Yeah, Push & Believe.
You got it.
Little Real, yes!
- Let me say, let me
correct you, it's Lil Rel.
- My bad, let's correct.
- It's okay, it's Lil Rel.
- Rail?
- Not Real.
- Wait, it's like railroad?
- Yes, R--
- Rail?
- It's R-E-L but
it's said like rail,
R-A-L.
- Rail?
- Lil
- Lil?
- Rel.
- Lil Rel.
- So you're from Chicago.
- Born and raised, from
the west side of Chicago.
Where the Chicago
Bulls played at.
- Yes, United Center
or Chicago Stadium?
- United Center.
Michael Jordan.
- Heard of him.
- He's the greatest ever.
- He just turned 50
and he's still going.
- He has really red eyes now.
- He does, what is
that from smoking pot?
No?
- You gettin' on my bad list.
Number one, you said my
fucking name wrong, okay.
It's Lil Rel.
- Little Rail.
- Now you're saying
Michael Jordan's on drugs.
Let's move on.
- I'm off my game, forgive me.
I don't have my notes, my
writers dropped the ball.
Where are my notes?
You're embarrassing me.
Okay, it says here you were on
BET Comic View.
- Why did you--
- That's not a surprise.
- But why did you have,
I'm looking at your notes.
- Well.
- Why did you have
to start with BET though?
There's other shit before that.
This is at the bottom,
there's other stuff on top.
Why did you start with BET?
Okay, we know I'm black,
I'm not light-skinned.
I'm not your color, look
put your hand next to mine.
We know what it is.
You didn't have to
start out with BET.
I'm embarrassed about this.
- Okay.
- You know?
- Yell at my writers,
they'll take it.
- Who wrote BET down?
Okay!
- You changed your
name, your real name is
it says here, Milton Howery.
Am I saying that right?
- Right.
- Howery?
Okay I said it right.
- I haven't changed it but--
- Thank God.
- Understand this, 'cause it's
easy for you to say Milton.
Milton, I come from a
long line of Miltons.
So my father's name is Milton,
my grandfather's name is Milton,
his father was named Milton.
I'm really Milton the fourth.
I'm really like, royalty.
- Yeah.
- [Lil Rel] Of the Milton--
- Hip-Hop royalty.
- Hip-Hop Milton
royalty, yeah, I'm--
- Kanye West.
Cruising in Chicago.
You got it.
- Why did you bring up Kanye?
- He's from Chicago.
- [Lil Rel] I don't give a fuck.
- "Call a man."
- This is my moment, okay?
- [Brody] Okay.
- You think Kanye talking about
me in his fucking interview?
- No.
- No, he ain't.
Don't bring Kanye
up no fuckin' more.
- [Brody] Yes.
- Go on to the next thing.
- Okay.
- Why you shaking, you nervous?
- I'm a little nervous.
- Why?
Why you scared of me, huh?
I don't even have
fucking facial hair.
I'm wearing glasses.
I'm scared of you.
- Why?
- You have a kidnapper shirt
on, you got a kidnapper's beard
- This shirt is 818 till I die.
- I don't know what the
fuck that means man.
- San Fernando Valley.
- I don't know what San,
see that sound like a
kidnapper city, I'm sorry.
You gonna kidnap me after this.
- No, no.
- This is not Comedy
Central is it?
Who are you people?
- This is the Al
Jazeera Network.
And you are on hidden camera.
Yes!
I'm kidding about that.
Where were you in 1999?
- In high school.
- Okay, I was on Premium Blend.
- So it took you over,
let's see, 14 years
to come up with a good
half-hour for Comedy Central?
- I hope it's good.
- That is fucked up, Brody.
- Yeah, it's f'ed
up they wouldn't let
me come back sooner.
Right?
Let's protest, let's
get Farrakhan out there
and protest, what
is wrong with that?
How dare you!
- Why the fuck you, I'm Baptist.
I'm not a fucking Muslim.
- Positive energy?
Push?
Believe?
- Fuck you Brody!
- What a great video.
Like it, subscribe, click it.
Comedy Central, in it, Facebook?
We got you covered.
Twitter?
We're there too.
Friendship?
I know you got that.
Tell everybody!
We're in this together,
it's teamwork.
I scratch your back,
you shave mine.
Boom!
Laughter.
You got it.
Click, subscribe, all that.
I'm gonna click.
I'm gonna believe
and you should too.
(exciting synth music)
(low rumbling)